hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move university comm
thank you and enjoy so if you recall
from part 9 on lipids we talked about
sphingolipids and their structure so
sphingolipids have a single seen
backbone which is highlighted here in
purple and they have an acyl group
attached at carbon number two of the
backbone via an amide linkage here and
then the polar head group is basically
this X here and this X is it could be a
phospho alcohol or it could be a shiver
of some sort or sugars so how are these
things made well there's four steps so
in that sense they're similar to the way
in which literal phospholipids are made
because there's also four steps to make
those what's the first thing that we
have to do is with the form is finger
nine backbone it's finger nine backbone
and how many carbons is that well as you
can see from here there are 18 and 16 of
those carbons come from palmitoyl koay
which is an activated fatty acyl coa and
two of them come from an amino acid
serine which actually has three carbons
want to pay attention to where that
third apartment actually goes the second
thing that needs to happen is that we
need to attach a fatty acyl CoA as an
acyl group to the backbone via an amide
linkage that's where we see at so we see
that there and at which carbon of the
backbone is occur we can see that that
occurs at carbon number two so c2 I'll
even put that in orange to indicate that
we're talking about that carbon number
in orange the next thing that we need to
do is have the desaturation
of a spinning of the signaling backbone
between carbons four so let's again
Orange let's do C 4 and C 5 so we can
see that right here between carbon 4
card and 5 in purple here there is a
double bond so that has to be input in
the third step
and the question there is uh what's the
name of the parent compound formed by
this step in that step what will happen
is that we will make the parent compound
of sphingolipids which is called
ceramide after that a last thing to do
is have the attachment of the polar head
group depending on what it is so these
first three steps here occur in the
smooth ER and this last one occurs in
the Golgi ok cool let's move on and see
these steps so first up we've got serine
here the amino acid and we have
palmitate okay that activated fatty acyl
ka and so these two were to come
together to form this finger named
backbone and - only two of the three
carbons in syrian are actually going to
be a part of the backbone it's this
first carbon able to convert number one
here and carbon number two right above
it the alpha carbon and actually what
leaves is this third carbon here that's
part of the carboxyl group that's going
to leave as carbon dioxide when these
two indents another thing is that the
coenzyme a will also leave and what if
essentially what will happen is that
we'll have the chain of HA Motoko a
connected to the serine basically carbon
number two is sort of going to be
connected to carbon number three and
that's what we get over here in this
molecule three ketose finger name so now
these two carbons here from from serine
and the rest of this molecule coming
from pol Motoko a alright so so serene
and palmitate Ocoee make up the backbone
in that first step the next thing that
we need to do is that we need to take
this carbon number three here turn this
ketone into an alcohol to give our to
give them all your finger need to form
the the actual backbone because that
that carbonyl does not exist
the industry no lipids so that needs to
be reduced and the reducing agent for
that is going to be NADPH so now we have
the alcohol and we've made spinning so
step one forming this finding backbone
is complete the next thing we need to do
is add the acyl group via the amide
linkage so that's what happened here at
carbon number two of the backbone we
connected an acyl group to that nitrogen
there so we go from an amino group to an
amide and we need to have an acyl Co a
come in and the coenzyme a will fall off
and that will give us an acyl n a so
spinning which is just spinning with an
acyl group attached at the end of the
backbone so that's step two there
step three is going to be importing the
desaturation between carbons four and
five so right here there's a single bond
that we're starting off with we need
that to be a double bond and the enzyme
that's going to accomplish that is
called a mixed function oxidase which
we've mentioned a couple times before
and that of course requires NADH as well
as molecular oxygen and that will give
us ceramide which is the parent compound
of sphingolipids so I'll just make that
note here the parent compound of
sphingolipids okay now once we have
ceramide the last step is simply to
attach the polar head group so that
would be step four so we can either have
a situation in which the polar head
group is some sort of sugar or
collection of sugars in this case I've
drawn glucose here as the as part of the
polar head group now that'll give us a
cerebro side or we can have a phospho a
phospho a la port in as the polar head
group to give us a sphingomyelin so
let's start with the cerebral side up
here in order to get a cerebro side and
attach this sugar on here this is
the glucose that needs to come from an
activated buco so specifically a UDP
glucose and we've seen UDP glucose in
glycogen synthesis so UDP glucose is
basically an activated boot Coast is
activated and that's going to come in
and the glucose would be attached while
the UDP will fall off we could also add
galactose using UDP galactose okay once
we create the cerebro side we can add
more sugars to give us global sides and
if we add a sialic acid or even more
sugars we can get ganglia sides as well
if you're unfamiliar with these terms or
they seem kind of fishy I would
encourage you to go back and watch the
sphingolipids portion of the lipids
series maybe I'll have a link to that
somewhere now if we wanted to make a
sphingomyelin we have to add a phosphor
oklahoman where's that phosphor alcohol
kind of portion can actually come from
here the way I've drawn it I've drawn
phosphocholine so this is choline over
here that's part of this Fingal myelin
and so so where does that actually come
from that's going to come from an actual
phospholipid so in this case we're
talking about adding choline so we'd
have to use the phospholipid
phosphatidylcholine phosphatidyl choline
the entire phospholipid would come in
and basically give its phospho choline
portion to ceramide to give this finger
the sphingomyelin here and what would be
left of the phosphatidyl choline would
just be the dies of glycerol portion so
basically the phospho alcohol portion of
phosphatidylcholine would come off and
attach to ceramide to make the
sphingomyelin here this could of course
work with other phospholipids or
glycerophospholipid specifically like
phosphatidyl ethanolamine
or phosphatidylserine so this here is a
little bit different than
glycerophospholipid synthesis where we
just added a CDP choline or a CDP
ethanol I mean to get the phospho the
basic
either the polar head group attached to
give our final product in this case we
actually have to take another lipid and
basically steal its polar head group so
I hope that video wraps up spinkle lipid
synthesis fairly well thank you for
watching thanks for watching don't
forget to Like comment subscribe and be
sure to share the video with anyone who
you think might find helpful thanks and
happy studying